double down
[Music]
why do nina
and anna hate each other i think one's a
better assassin than the other right who
do you think is better
i honestly think nina's better why
okay i before we answer the question why
they hate each other why are you hating
on anna look i just think anna
rubs it in
nina she's trying too hard nina's just
trying to live out here and i feel like
anna is the one who goes out of our way
to mess with nina like that's that's
just my perception of i could be wrong
and that to me i feel like that just
means nina is more about her business
you know how i know she's about her
business because she had a whole nother
game outside of the fighting genre to
let people know that she's about killing
people
interesting reasoning all right so
you're using accolades you're using
accolades so this is my personal take on
why they hate each other so nina she
succeeded her father
in being an assassin okay okay for the
country
he died
and anna felt that it was nina's fault
that she died obviously they had that
confrontation in front of his grave they
ended up slapping each other they
slapped each other every single day
they even have special slaps in the game
how can she slap go on so
that being said
anna has always taken it very personally
to to not only
go above and beyond her sister but also
be that person to be in her way
she has always been trying to block or
stop her from doing her job so nina was
put in after kazuo captured her because
his version of the mishimazu captured
her put her into cryosleep from between
tekken 2 and tekken 3.
anna voluntarily put herself into
cryosleep just so she could come out the
same time to battle nina when she came
back out that's crazy to me that's right
right like like nina's out of the
picture and you're like you you know let
sleeping dogs like you know what let
them do their thing she was like nah
freeze me too so i could beat her up
when i get out you said she did what
that's why she put me in the tube that's
why i think i want to go on a tube
that's that's why you think
that's pettiness she doesn't need to be
an assassin she's just being an ass and
i like that
i i don't like that that's that that's
why i said that's why i said nina's
better that's why i said nina's better
she's just trying to live out here
we're gonna have to agree to disagree
here
but i think that's why they hate each
other obviously it stems back it's a
family thing you know family things are
very complicated i don't want to really
say who's right and who's wrong but i'll
just say who's better and i think it's
anna what
[Music]
me
[Music]
you